chaque occasion est bonne pour le
pouvoir turc de tacler le gouvernement
français fréquemment recep tayyip
erdogan se place en procureurs d'un
procès en islamophobie intenté contre
emmanuel macron et la loi séparatisme
adopté à l'assemblée nationale n'a fait
qu'accentuer la pression exercée depuis
ankara sur les autorités françaises
deux fédérations franco turc membre du
conseil français du culte musulman ont
ainsi refusé de signer la fameuse charte
attestant du respect des principes
républicains et vu les liens qui
existent entre ces organisations et le
pouvoir turc
certains y voient la main des douanes
une enquête parue le 6 février dernier
dont le journal du dimanche évoque
d'ailleurs une stratégie d'infiltration
du pouvoir turc en france s'appuyant sur
des notes et services de renseignement
l'article parle d'une emprise d'ankara
sur la diaspora turque
grâce à un réseau d'associations d'école
et par une présence grandissante dans la
sphère politique locale cette emprise
lui permet à la fois de disposer de
relais pour sa propagande de surveiller
les exilés et de juguler les mouvements
d'opposition plus à l'aise pour
s'exprimer dans des démocraties il veut
étouffer toute contestation dans l'oeuf
observe-t-on au ministère des affaires
étrangères
une enquête alarmante à laquelle a
répondu l'ambassadeur de turquie en
france qui s'offusquent que des éléments
avancés dans l'article et balaie ces
accusations pour l'avocat franco turc
sel sucre demir il s'agit d'une
tentative de déstabilisation
pour elle c'est que la france et la
turquie malheureusement ont des intérêts
divergents et de temps à autre on a en
france dès volonté de vouloir fragiliser
la position turque en prêtant à la
turquie des choses qui n'existent pas
comme par exemple ce qui est sous-tendue
par ses articles des jdd les tensions
entre paris et ankara se multiplient
outre les propos d'erdogan qui avait
conduit à des manifestations hostiles à
emmanuel macron en turquie les intérêts
des deux pays alliés au sein de l'otan
divers
sur plusieurs dossiers méditerranée
orientale haut karabagh syrie les points
de friction sont nombreux des
oppositions géo politique et idéologique
qui participe donc à la dégradation des
relations entre les deux pays
dernier exemple en date la décision de
l'université francophone de galatasaray
à istanbul d'imposer aux professeurs
français qui travaillent de nouveaux
critères de maîtrise de la langue turque
s'il ne conteste pas le fond les
principaux intéressés s'étonne de la
soudaineté d'une telle décision qui
pourrait remettre en cause leur séjour
dans la métropole turque
en voulant lutter en france contre le
communautarisme le gouvernement s'expose
donc aux critiques virulentes d'ankara
des liens distendus illustré par le
manque de dialogue entre les deux
présidents en arrivant au pouvoir en mai
2010 est emmanuel macron avait dû
rapidement se pencher sur l'arrestation
d'un journaliste français en turquie
près de quatre ans plus tard le dossier
turc continue de préoccuper la
diplomatie française